one thing that kind of blows my mind
maybe you can tell me your thoughts
about it is
the the way evolution works with natural
selection
is uh based on the final sort of
the entirety of the orchestra
musical performance right and then but
there's these
incredibly rich structural things
like each one of them doing their own
little job that somehow work together
like
the evolution selects based on the final
result and yet
all the individual pieces are doing like
infinitely
minuscule specific things how the heck
does that work
it's a very good insight and you can
even go beyond that
and basically say evolution doesn't
select at the level of an organism
it actually selects that level of whole
environments whole ecosystems
so let me break this down so you
basically have
at the very bottom every single
nucleotide
being selected but then that nucleotide
function is selected
at the level of you know each gene
and every not even each gene each
gene regulatory control element and then
those control elements are basically
converging
onto the function of the gene and many
genes are converging onto the function
of one cell
and many cells are converging to the
function of one tissue
or organ and all of these organs are
converging
onto the level of an organism but now
that organism is not in isolation
so if you basically think about why is
altruism for example
a thing why are people being nice to
each other
it was probably selected and it was
probably selected
because those species that were just
nasty to each other didn't survive
as a species and now if you think about
symbiosis of you know
uh there's plants for example that love
co2 and there's humans that love
o2 and we're sort of you know trading
um different types of gases
to each other if you look at
ecosystems where one organism which is
really nasty
that organism actually died because
everyone they were being nasty to was
killed off
and then that kind of you know
universe of life is gone so basically
what emerges
is selection at so many different layers
of benefit including
you know all of these nucleotides within
a body
interacting for the emergent functions
at the body level yeah i wonder i wonder
if it's possible to break it down into
levels that's
selection even beyond humans like
you said environment but there's
environments at all different levels too
right
at the minuscule at the organ level the
tissue level like you said
maybe at the microscopic level it would
be fascinating if like
there's a kind of selection going on at
like
both the quantum level and like the
the galaxy level yeah yeah right yeah so
so all the different
forms yeah let's again sort of break
down these different layers so basically
if you think about the environment in
which a gene operates
that gene of course the first definition
of environment that we think of
is pollution or sunlight or heat or
cold and so forth that's the external
environment
but every gene also operates at the
level of the internal cellular
environment that it's in
if i take a gene from say an african
individual and i put it in a european
context
will it perform the same way probably
not because there's a cellular context
of thousands of other genes that that
gene has co-evolved with
you know in the out of africa event and
you know all of this
sort of human history of evolution so
basically
if you look at neandertal genes for
example
which again happen long after that out
of africa event
there's incompatibilities between
neanderthal genes
and modern human genes that can lead to
diseases
so in the context of the neonatal genome
that gene version that allele was fine
but in the context of the modern human
genome that neanderthal gene version
is actually detrimental so it's it's you
know that cellular environment
constitutes the genetics of that gene
but also of course all of the
epigenomics
of that gene it's fascinating that the
the gene
has a history i mean we talked about
this a little bit last time but
just and and then some of your research
goes into that but
the genes as they are today have have a
story
from the beginning of time and then some
sometimes their story was like their
path was useful
for survival for the particular
organisms and sometimes not
that's fascinating
you